alors parlons évidemment financièrement
oui il y a eu nous le disons chaque
année et ses croissants une forme de
tutélisation de nos finances
sur la taxe professionnelle plus la taxe
d'habitation puis la CVAE aujourd'hui
c'est fiscalité qui permettait d'assumer
une responsabilité devant le
contribuable
et donc qui nous permettait aussi
d'avoir les ressources nécessaires sans
taper telle ou telle catégorie
aujourd'hui il est propriétaire
l'évoquions tout à l'heure sont victimes
de la réorganisation de cette fiscalité
locale nous n'avons plus de leviers
quasiment plus de leviers fiscaux et je
crois que c'est très grave parce que
cette nationalisation de fiscalité
locale et j'appelle l'attention de
chacun notamment des journalistes je
vais venir sur les commentaires que j'ai
entendu depuis 5 jours
elle se fait dans un contexte où les
prélèvements obligatoires eux augmentent
chaque suppression de fiscalité locale
ne se traduit pas par une baisse de la
pression fiscale dans ce cas-là nous
pourrions accepter l'effort conjoint
puisque les prélèvements obligatoires
viennent de passer à nouveau les 45 %
impôts échange
et selon les sources
des services de l'État au CDE plus de
47%
et donc
ce mouvement de tutélisation de nos
ressources
qui est une utilisation assez
pernicieuse de surcroît nous laisse
apparaître comme revendicative par ou
presque pleurnicha c'est pas le cas on
ne demande pas de l'aide
on demande à affronter ensemble des
crises en commun notamment sur l'énergie
mais sur la relation financière
là l'indexation de la DGF c'est pas une
demande inflationniste c'est tout
simplement le respect de la parole de
l'État puisque
lorsqu'à chaque fois depuis la
suppression de la patente qui a été
créée une dotation c'était soit pour
compenser la suppression du fiscalité
soit pour accompagner un transfert de
charges de responsabilité dans quelques
financements et que jusqu'au début des
années 2000 la dotation suivait
l'inflation cette faisait même pas
l'objet et y compris dans les années 70
et début 80 lorsque l'inflation était
très forte plus la moitié de la
croissance
puisque l'État a une dynamique de charge
personne ne dit à l'état tiens baisser
la TVA pour que le montant reste stable
en ne recourant
nous voulons que ces ressources qui sont
censées appartenir aux collectivités
restent collectivités
alors je regardais les bandeaux sur les
chaînes info les maires demandent est-ce
que l'État est assez etc je le dis en
sincérité je pense que ce langage ne
fait comme disait Togoville énervaient
les cœurs et les âmes parce que
j'ai même entendu un ministre dire
l'état de l'aide les mères beaucoup plus
qu'avant d'abord c'est pas les mères
c'est on a de la population quoi les
communes ensuite
faut bien voir que c'est une forme de
paternalisme d'État que nous n'acceptons
plus tout simplement parce que nous
votons des budgets à l'équilibre parce
que quel que soit les circonstances
comme dans une entreprise nous ne
empruntons pas pour notre fonctionnement
parce que nous ne sommes pas un problème
pour les comptes publics le problème des
comptes publics en France vient des
contes de l'État et des comptes sociaux
dans le déficit de l'État et la
présentation à Bruxelles et nous
l'avions évoqué au téléphone madame la
Première ministre
l'état déduit les excédents des
collectivités avec ce paradoxe parfois
la Cour des comptes disait regardez il y
a un tas d'or et puis après on nous dit
de faire regardez ces mères qui
dépensent
le total de dépenses de toutes les
collectivités territoriales Région
Département bloc communale représente
29% 19%, 19% du total de la dépense
publique en France la moyenne européenne
selon le degré de centralisation ou de
décentralisation voire Ferrari c'est
entre 31 et
40%. donc nous représentant moins y
compris en pourcentage de PIB que le
reste de nos partenaires européens en
dépense celui dans les collectivités en
revanche le représentant 70% de
l'investissement
[Musique]